my subject today is entitled the third
trial of jesus
father we want to thank you for this
beautiful time to worship the lord
we thank you for this privilege
i pray father that you will
hide me behind the cross of jesus
we want to lift up the lord because only
when we lift up jesus
all will be drawn to him
i pray lord
that the words would be yours
and just the war is mine
to bless each one of us in christ's name
amen
the scripture says i was glad when they
said unto me let us go into the house of
the lord
but you're not able to come to the house
of the lord because of the pandemic
but you can still be glad
in your own houses
because the lord is omnipresent he's not
only in his holy temple
he's also in your houses because your
body is the temple
of god
i want to welcome each one of you
from wherever you are joining
a very warm welcome and a happy sabbath
and may god's spirit
speak to each one of us as we open our
hearts
as we listen
to his words
we thank god for technology
that makes it possible
for
the worship to come to your own homes
and we thank god for
the media team as well
my subject today is entitled the third
trial of jesus
in my previous presentation
why was jesus silent we looked at the
first trial and the second trial we
looked at the jewish trial
and the roman trial the religious
and
the civil
trial
we see
it was and we saw it was an absolute
mockery
to justice
we saw 10 outstanding reasons last time
as to why
that trial
was totally
illegal and unlawful
in the jewish trial
they needed at least two witnesses to
say something two should agree
there were many false witnesses the
bible says
in matthew 26 59 and
and the chief priests and elders
and all the councils sought
false witnesses against jesus i mean
they're searching for false witness
because they couldn't find
anything against christ to put him to
death
but
found none
yea
though they sought many false witnesses
though many false witnesses came yet
found they none
and
the last came
to
false
witnesses and they were so happy that
two people could say the same thing and
what did they say
matthew 26 61-63
this fellow said i am able to destroy
the temple of god
and to build it in three days it was
false witness too because jesus did not
say he's going to destroy he said you
destroy i will build it
and the high priest arose and said unto
him answer us down a thing
what is this which these witness against
thee
but jesus held a space
he didn't answer there were false
witnesses
lies will take care of itself
and then the high priest
asked him a very personal question of
his identity
the highest person asking this under
oath and what did he say
in matthew 26 63 64 and the high priest
answered and said unto him i endure thee
by the living god care first are you
blind the living god is standing in
front of you
that thou tell us whether thou be the
christ the son of god
are you deaf carefuls did you hear the
father say this is my beloved son at
baptism
jesus saith unto him
thou
hast said
meaning
that's correct what you said
i am the son
of the living god
and then christ proceeded
to give a proof
he said i'm going to give you producer
proof later
later
he said
nevertheless i say unto you
hereafter shall he see the son of man
seated on the right hand of power
and coming in the clouds of heaven
wow
and see how they reacted
and the high priestess clothes saying he
had spoken blasphemy
what further need are we of witnesses
let's dismiss the witnesses you get a
witness from him
that was illegal to
condemn someone by their own testimony
we saw it last time
behold he have heard his blasphemy what
think he
they answered and said he is guilty
of
death
and they proceed
to condemn the prince of life
to death
and see how
they reacted
to the seemingly blasphemous statement
they physically abuse
the holy one of israel the bible says
matthew 26 67
then they spit
in his
face and beat him
with your fists
and some slapped him
you know to spit on someone's face in
oriental time
was the worst thing that you could do
it was worse than taking your shoes and
slapping and hitting somebody to spit
on someone's face
and that too
whose face that was
the face
of god
they beat him they slapped him
have you seen in any court where the
judges get down and start thrashing the
victim
what an illegal procedure
and then
they drag him to the roman code to have
their sentence executed pilot conducts
his own investigation he realizes
something is terribly wrong here
and thrice he declared
i find in him
no fault
at all
he goes back
back and forth three times no fault
and then jesus you know
there's a lot of noise going on pilate
is telling him speak
pilate asked him saying again saying
answer us down nothing behold how many
things they witness against thee
but jesus ans yet answered nothing so
that pilate marvel we saw that in in our
last presentation why was jesus silent
but
once
in the roman code as well
jesus broke his silence
because he asked him a very personal
question
about his identity
pilate therefore said unto him are thou
a king then
jesus answered
thou sayest i am a king
to this end was i born and for this
cause came i into this world that i
should bear witness unto the truth and
he also told pilate my kingdom
is not
of this world
i'm a king
of heaven
and see how the roman coat reacted
because he made that divine kingly claim
the bible tells us
john 19 verse 1 then pilate therefore
took chases and scourged him
and the soldiers played at a crown of
thorns
and put it on his head
and they put it on him a purple robe and
said hail king of the jews and
they smote him
with their hands this cursed them first
we are told the skirting by the romans
was a horrible thing
they would have in the whip
glass pieces
rusty nails
bones
and those tough roman soldiers would
whip so hard
on that naked back
and chunks of flesh would come as they
pulled away back
and they whipped him several times he
was completely opened up
his back was lacerated
he took it all and then they put a crown
of thorns in elsewhere they say they
took a reed and hit it so that it would
sit nicely
on his head it went deep into his temple
and they smote him
with their hands can you imagine the
roman soldiers smiting jesus i mean he
was already tired
they beat him up so badly and then
and then
they crucify him
hitting those rusty nails into that
blessed arms of palms of jesus
so mercilessly he never protested but he
cried in pain because he was human as
well
and then
the way they plunged that cross
in the hole that they prepared they just
thrusted
and he came hanging almost bouncing
with the back open terrible
beloved how
how much jesus suffered there but there
was one more trial
which we are going to look at this
morning this afternoon
the third
trial of
jesus the first trial was the jewish
trial religious trial the second trial
the roman trial the civil trial the
third trial would be conducted by the
highest court
the heavenly court chaired by his own
father
abraham understood god is very fair and
just you know when god brings his
judgment he said
in genesis 18 25 shall not the judge of
all the earth do right the first two
trials did not do it right shall the
will god the father do right here in the
third trial of jesus
well let's
take a look behind the scene now pull
the screen apart to look at the third
trial of jesus
well the first trial and the second
trial are clearly spelt out in scripture
but the third trial is there
it's not seen in the broad daylight
because it happened
in darkness
and may god open our eyes
to catch a glimpse
of the third trial of jesus
the bible tells us in matthew 27 45 now
from the sixth hour that's 12 noon
jewish time sixth hour
12 noon our time roman time there was
darkness
over all the land
and to the ninth hour
darkness and luke adds in luke 23 verse
44 and there was darkness all
over the earth
until the ninth hour
the whole earth was enveloped in
darkness especially the land of judea
and gross darkness
around
the cross
why
well we need to look at another mountain
where darkness was there and you will
understand why the darkness occurred at
calvary
we read in exodus 20 and verse 21 moses
drew near unto the thick darkness
where
god
was
you know god came down on mount sinai
and he brought darkness because no man
can see my glory and yet live he said
and god did not come alone on mount
sinai the bible tells us in deuteronomy
33 and verse 2 and he said
the lord came from mount sinai and he
came with ten thousands of saints
the hebrew word for saints is holy ones
or angels ten thousands angels came
from his right hand went a fiery law
for them
beloved there was darkness
on that mountain
darkness on this mountain
the psalmist tells us he made darkness
his secret place
his pavilion round about him where
dark waters and thick clouds
of the sky
god makes darkness
his secret place
for sinners
yes
ellen white tells us in desire of ages
in that thick darkness
god's presence
was hidden
he makes darknesses pavilion and
conceals his glory from human eyes
god
and his holy angels
were beside the cross
the father was with his son
yet his presence was not revealed
had his glory flashed forth from the
cloud every human beholder would have
been destroyed now you know why there
was darkness from 12 o'clock to 3
o'clock
god came down
with his holy angels the third trial of
jesus the heavenly trial
on mount sinai
in that thick darkness god wrote his law
which would be the standard
of human judgment
at mount calvary
in the thick darkness
god was executing the penalty of
transgression
on the representative of humanity jesus
christ
as the lamb of god
takes away the sin of the world
the bible says sin is the transgression
of the law
and wages of sin
is death
he had to taste death
for every man if not you and i
would have to die
forever
you know god did not come out come down
alone he came down with all his angels
because the great controversy started in
heaven
with an angel called
lucifer
he accused god in christ he was jealous
of christ you know christ sitted at the
right hand of god and now christ hanging
on the cross
what a contrast
the great controversy
split
the angelic family in heaven
one third
went on lucifer's side two-thirds
decided to remain on christ's side we
are told in the pen of inspiration that
angels were actually shifting
places
till they finally decided okay to third
they said no no i think
god is right
one third said no no
lucifer is right
the accused christ of you know god of
wanting to be exalted sitting on that on
that lofty throne and receiving the
adoration of angels and he said i want
to be like the most high
and here that same god the son of god
of whom he was jealous
is not on a throne
but on a cross
not with
a diadem of glory
but with a crown of thorns on his head
not only holy angels were around the
cross with the father we also told evil
angels surrounded the cross
and so
god lets this holy angel see
as he conducts the third trial of jesus
in fact in the trial of the human family
as well angels participate god doesn't
do it alone not that god needs help god
knows the end from the beginning
brother controversy involves everyone
now it's an open contest
daniel 7 verse 10 and fiery stream
issued and came forth from before him
thousand thousands ministered unto him
and ten thousand times ten thousand
stood before him they are the angels
and the judgment was set
and the books
were open god doesn't need books
where angels need to look at it because
they need to see all the details god
opens up
in front of the angels
and jesus makes a very interesting
statement
after the darkness was passed
at 3 pm
roman time
that unveils to our view what actually
transpired
in that thick
darkness
and at the ninth hour jesus cried with a
loud voice saying
eloy eloi
lama sabatstani in aramaic
which is being interpreted
my god my god
why
has thou forsaken me
christ heard that verdict
that final verdict
that he has to die
because
he was carrying the sins of the whole
world and the wages of sin
is death
ellen white writes about that mysterious
statement the father's glory and
sustaining presence had left him he was
forsaken
and despair pressed
its crushing weight of darkness upon him
and forced
from his pale and quivering
lips
the anguished cry
my god
why
hast thou
forsaken me
he was forsaken
at the jewish trial
at the roman trial
but what broke his heart
the most was
when the heavenly trial took place
and his own father
turned his back away
forsook him
to die
for a guilty race
you know in the roman trial
and the jewish trial
jesus knew it was a mockery to justice
he held his peace
and we see
in scripture
when jesus comes the second time
when probation is closed and he comes to
to judge the living and the dead
there will be some people who think they
they should make it and they say lord
lord
and this is how jesus is going to answer
in matthew 7 23 i never knew you depart
from me e that work iniquity because a
holy god and sinful man cannot get
together they are the opposite only
because of calvary and the plan of
salvation sinners are welcomed unto once
probation is closed it's done
and here
jesus takes the sin of humanity upon
himself and he was and for he hath made
him to be sinfulous who knew no sin
he was made
sin
on the cross
as the sin of the whole world was put on
him
i never knew you depart from me that
work iniquity and now the iniquity of
the whole world is upon one man
and the father turns away as if to say i
don't know you
and he departed
and jesus cried
my god
you know on another mountain
the father came down
it was bright
and glorious
matthew 17 verse 2
and he was transfigured before them and
his eye and his face did shine
as the sun
and his raiment was white as the light
this is opposite to mount calvary
the sun is shining in its strength it
looks like the sun came down as a son of
god
divinity flashes through his humanity
and the father is there in that white
cloud the bright cloud
while yet speak behold a bright cloud
overshadowed them and behold a voice out
of the cloud which said this is my
beloved son in whom i am well pleased
here e him
my beloved son bright cloud
the father's
brightness overshadowing as well
at mount of transfiguration moses and
elijah came and they were talking to him
they talked about his disease about his
death they talked to him but while he is
dying
all the angels are there the father is
there and no one is talking
you know conversation at least helps
sometimes
all lines cut off
now we'll look at the books
of judgment
the bible tells us
about the judgment of humanity every
single person the judgment was set and
the books were open and jesus came as
man
and he had to be judged now
heaven's coat descended
judgment was set and the books were
opened the father takes the book of
jesus
because he had a history
when he came as a man
from bethlehem
all the way
his infancy his
childhood adult would manhood
perfect blemishless
christ as a lamb without blemish and
without spot the angels were stunned
sin not
either in thought or word or action
intention nothing
satan tried all his temptations christ
thrust it
by depending on his father in the holy
spirit lamb without blemish and spot
lily pure lily of the valley in the dust
in the muddy gutter
the pure white rose of sharon
the lily
of the valley
but he was dying there not for himself
he was dying
for humanity fallen humanity
isaiah tells us all we like sheep have
gone astray we have turned everyone his
own way and the lord hath laid on him
the iniquity of us all
he had no iniquity at all
but there was a transfer the lord laid
on him the inequity from our books the
darkness
the dark sense we're all transferred to
his book
can you imagine all the sins of all the
billions of people from adam's time to
to the end of time all the sins
a data transfer of our sin
on this on the book of christ
and it piles up from earth to heaven
the angels are mystified now what would
god do
sin has to be judged he was made to be
sin for us
he carried the sin of the whole world
and he had to be judged
for that
ellen white says
god
suffered
his wrath
against transgression to fall
on his beloved son
god suffered
that's the old english of god loved god
permitted
his ross
to follow knew
on his son
in my sermon who killed jesus
we saw that story where god illustrated
the struggle of abraham when god called
him
to take the life of his own son god
suffered
literally suffered god's struggles
as he had to
let his wrath
fall on his beloved son because god is
holy
he cannot excuse sin
he has made a provision for sinners but
the provision has to pay the price
isaiah heard the verdict in that
darkness
and he penned it down
the verdict at the end of three hours of
darkness
it pleased the lord
to bruise him
he hath put him
to grief now this is mysterious
it please the lord you know the word
please is used for jesus
twice
by the father
at baptism god said this is my beloved
son in whom i am well pleased
and now at calvary
god is well pleased
to bruise him
wow
he struggled he suffered but then there
was something else
the pleasing
at the same time
you know god hates
sin and he hates even to punish sinners
because they are made in his own image
you know as parents we we love our
children but sometimes we have to
discipline but it hurts us
it hurts god when he when he brings his
judgment god said as i live say of the
lord i have no pleasure
in the death of the wicked you know some
people they portray god he's going to
laugh and you know he's going to enjoy
when he sees people burning in hell
that's a lie
i have no pleasure
in the death of the wicked it hurts him
terribly but when it came to the death
of his own son it says it pleased the
lord
to bruise him
wow
what a mystery
because god saw
in the bruising of his son in the death
of his son
the salvation of humanity
god saw
that if he sacrifices his only begotten
son
he will have many
sons and daughters
in glory
that was the only thing
that pleased him
otherwise the father suffered
to bring his wrath you know god cries
if we can cry
sometimes men you know
try not to cry
but we all cry
at least inside
but we all shed tears
and do you know god also cries
when he brings his judgment upon people
who have turned his back on him the
bible says in jeremiah 13 17 my soul
shall weep in secret places
mine i shall weep soar
you know bible tells us in revelation
god shall wipe away all tears from our
eyes at the end
but who is going to wipe god's tears
away
he'll weep in secret places
and what was his secret place
the darkness
he made darkness a secret place he
brought darkness there he didn't want
anyone to see the third trial because
the intensity of jesus suffering was so
much ellen white says god didn't want
anyone to see that it is beyond
understanding god says listen
don't even look at it
it'll make you so feel so terrible
of what he went through
and in that darkness his secret place
the father
was crying
listen to me
there was a fountain of blood
at the cross
and there was a fountain of tears
beside
the cross
the tears of a broken hearted father
and his angels and the blood
of his dear son
on the cross
there was three hours of
silence you know jesus spoke
seven words seven sentences on the cross
three before the darkness four after the
darkness but during the three hours of
darkness jesus did not speak a single
word because the third trial of jesus
was going on and you don't speak
when the coat is in session
and finally
the darkness disappeared i mean jesus
didn't speak a single word father also
didn't utter anything angels did not
communicate anything complete silence
and people also were shocked
what was happening the whole earth
enveloped in darkness
the angels also were peeping through the
cloud looking at this mysterious
suffering they were used to the glory of
the son of god they've never seen
anybody
suffering so much
they couldn't take it anymore the bible
says the suffering of christ the angels
desire to look it look into so he
brought them close view gave them a very
clear view but as it was unfolding in
the thick darkness it was getting too
much and we are told in the pen of
inspiration with amazement
angels witness the savior's despairing
agony
that is a very faint word
that humans could use
and the servant of the lord could best
think of despairing
agony
the hosts of heaven
wield their faces from the fearful sight
desire of ages
they said father we can't see it anymore
they will the faces oh
can you imagine if angels have to wail
their faces what must have been the
terrible suffering of christ
eternity will not be enough i i wonder
if god will ever open up that darkness
and show us what really happened it
might just crush us to death
they wield their faces i understand in
scripture you know just uh two times
angels wail their faces remember in
isaiah 6 when god was on the throne
jesus was on the throne the seraphims
they have six swings with two
they wield their faces saying holy holy
holy
because his glory and power and majesty
is too much they can't see it they wield
their faces but this wailing this was
extreme the other side too much and they
said we couldn't see this
wow
even jesus
did not utter a word
during the three hours
wondering what that verdict might be
and the verdict was out
at the end of three hours
there was darkness
over all the land until the ninth hour
and ninth hour it lifts up the father
goes
away with his angels jesus knew what
the sentence was
the bible says in galatians 3 13 christ
being made a
curse for us
for it is written
cursed is everyone that hangeth on a
tree
you know god cursed the ground initially
he cursed everyone there in the garden
when sin entered and now
when sin is about to exist exit
at calvary
he has to take the curse of everything
on his head
so that we can receive a blessing
they receive the curse
for you and me
jesus heart is completely broken
mark tells us that the ninth hour jesus
cried
with a loud voice saying
[Music]
lama savage tony
my god my god why hast thou
forsaken me
and as the father and the angels are
leaving they can hear the sun scream out
his voice
he was condemned
in all the three trials
but he broke his silence
in the jewish trial when the high priest
said are you the son of the living god
he said yes i am the son of the living
god he broke his silence at the roman
trial he said yes i am the king i sit on
the right hand of my father in heaven i
am he always loved to show his
connection to the almighty god but at
the third trial
the only hope that he had
that thin robe
back nothing for him to hold
except hold tight
that wooden cross that was suspended
between heaven and earth
a wicked
rejected by heaven and earth so that you
heaven and earth can be joined again
by that cross
he cried my god my god why hast thou
forsaken me
you know when judas betrayed him it was
hurting
but still he addressed him friend
said friend
betrays thou the son of man with a kiss
when peter denied him it deeply hurt
jesus this is the leader of the twelve
jesus had no rebuke for him with tender
mercy he looked at him
when the nation israel rejected him and
called for his blood
he came unto his own and his own
received in him not it's really hurting
he came to save them and the whole world
and they they say get away get lost
you're worthy of death
it was hurting but what hurt jesus more
was
when his father and the heavenly trial
moved out
a broken heart he cried
he was crying at the cross the father
was crying beside the cross the angels
were crying
and when jesus left the scene
it rained that afternoon as the
blackness
lifted up
to the heavens
it rained
not the showers
of rain that we get of
water but the tears
of a million angels
and the tears
of a god
whose fountain was broken
it
drained that day
and then
jesus knew it's time up
for him to give
up his breath
and with a loud voice addressing the
father who just left the scene he said
it
is
finished
something happened of course the
earthquake and a lot of things happen
we are told in the pen of inspiration
suddenly the gloom lifted from the cross
and in clear trumpet-like tones that
seemed to resound throughout creation
jesus christ it is finished father into
the hands i commend my spirit a light
and circle the cross
and the face of the savior shone with a
glory like the sun
he then bowed his head upon his breast
and died
light shown once again
that jesus indeed
has triumphed
yes he died
but you and i through that death
can live
you know the angels were crying all the
while they could not see the scene when
he said it is finished
and the light shone around him they said
wow thank god it's over
and they took their hops and their
trumpets and started singing
in praise and honor of the lamb that was
slain john heard it and he said i beheld
and i heard a voice of many angels the
number of them was ten thousand times
ten thousand and thousands of thousands
saying with a loud voice worthy islam
that was slain to receive power and
riches and wisdom and strength and honor
and glory and blessing satan accused
that jesus is not worthy of any of these
but they realize that they worthy is the
lamb that was slain
and when he comes a second time in power
and glory sitting in the right hand of
power the bible says every knee shall
bow every tongue shall confess that
jesus christ is lord to the glory of the
father and this music
it echoed throughout the universe as
other intelligent
beings from their other worlds joined in
the chorus
you know the scripture says there is joy
in the presence of the angels of god
over one sinner that repenteth
and this is not just one this is one
planet
that has come back to the fold of god
four thousand years lost
in sin
and now legally
one can you imagine the angel said wow
the planet is back
in the hand
of god and soon he's going to wind up
history you know in fact the creation
the morning stars sang together and all
the sons of god shouted for joy can you
imagine
how they would have sang and shouted for
joy at the redemption
of this planet earth
the bible tells us even god sings
it says in the book of zephaniah 3 13
the lord thy god in the midst of these
mighty he will joy
over thee with singing
if there was one time the father sang
for sure when jesus said it is finished
the father burst out
enjoy he wiped his tears away and said
son sleep for three days i'll see you
soon
joy oh thee
with singing
beloved
because of the third trial of jesus
because he was condemned
you and i have hope
the scripture says in romans 8 1
there is therefore now
no condemnation
to them which are in christ jesus
walk not after the flesh
but after
the spirit
you know that promise
i will never leave you nor forsake you
you know how god could make that promise
to sinful humanity
because of jesus he was forsaken on
behalf of humanity
and therefore the promise comes to us i
will never leave you sometimes if the
devil whispers to you you're a big
sinner god has left you you can remind
him listen god forsook his son
and he has promised not to never
leave me nor forsake forsake me
he was forsaken
so that you and i could be accepted
he was
condemned
so that you and i can be justified
he was put to death
so that you and i can have eternal life
he was bound
so that you and i
can be eternally free you said if the
son makes you free you
are free indeed beloved it's not the
first trial or the second trial that
brought our salvation it is the third
trial of jesus that brought us salvation
it was the toughest thing for god to do
and for christ to experience
but it was good news
it was good news we call it good friday
mysterious indeed as i close i want to
tell you true story of john griffith
and the bridge the bridge operator
john was working
in
early 1900s as a bridge operator
he operated the drawbridges
the drawbridge
that ran over the great mississippi
and he had a
an only child his boy little boy
eight-year-old greg
and one day the father said i'm going to
show you how i'm going to operate the uh
the bridge and
greg was so excited he poked in so many
questions as little boys of that age
and the father answered the question
and the bridge would would open up so
that the ship could pass through and
then they would shut the bridge so that
the train could go through
and there was a ship that was coming so
john opened and the little boy greg saw
he was so excited to see how his dad did
it he thought his dad was a real
champion a strong man
and then
the ship was passing by and
then john
heard the sound of an incoming train
memphis express at 107 pm
and john had to run and close the draw
bridges he told his son just be here
i'll come back and and he ran and you
know little boys like to follow their
father
and uh
john realized
just before he could
pull the liver he looked for his son his
son was missing
frantically he looked all around and he
found
john fell down craig fell down greg fell
down
into the giant gears
and he was screaming
craig my son get out from there get out
from there immediately but the noise of
the outgoing ship and the incoming train
was too loud he could not hear it
he was trapped there and john had to
decide now is he going to save his son
to go down there if he goes down to save
his son
400 people on that train would lose
their lives
he had to decide quickly what to do
with fear
and trembling he took the liver
and with a cry
i love you crick
i love you greg
he pulled the liver
crushing
his only begotten son
to death
and tears filled his eyes
he lost his son that day
and as the train was passing by he saw
people having fun somewhere playing
cards somewhere reading newspaper
somewhere looking out of the window and
waving at him some saw his steers and
said a mad man has come to work
and he screamed back he said guys you
don't know what i did for you today
i sacrificed my son so that you
might live they said he is nuts
they didn't know what happened
beloved the father saw a train
plunging into the sea
of hell
and on time he sent
his son
and he pulled
the liver
i love you my son
but it pleases the lord to bruise you
because i do not want
a sea of humanity to be lost
god laid a bridge
across the episode
dying there crushed
with a load of sin
on him
and because of that cross
jesus could say
i
am the way
the truth
and the life
no man can come to the father
but
by me
the third trial of jesus
it was
very hard
for the father
for the son
but it's good news for humanity thank
you father
thank you lord jesus
amen
i want you to listen to this
this song that sonali is going to say
listen to the words
and enjoy
the voice as well and may god bless
each one of us
so
[Music]
[Applause]
i
will
not boast in anything
[Music]
no gifts no power no wisdom
but i
will boast in
jesus christ
this death and
[Music]
his reward
i
cannot give an
answer
[Music]
but
these i know with all my heart
[Music]
his rewards
i know with all my heart
[Music]
his wounds have paid my
his rules
have paid
my
rent
[Music]
but this i know with all my heart
his wound has paid
my ransom
father
thank you for what you did 2 000 years
ago in that thick darkness
thank you for
opening us up a bit
of what transpired in that darkness
[Music]
it was dark for jesus
but it brought light to the whole world
it broke your heart
it broke the heart of the son of god
and the angels cried
[Music]
while people mocked
and people were jeering that day
heaven
and the universe
[Music]
the wonder struck
weeping
[Music]
father
i pray that we would ever be grateful
for the third trial of jesus because
that gives us hope
in our own heavenly trial
and thank you for the hope
now therefore there is no condemnation
to them who are in christ jesus
walk not after the flesh but after the
spirit
as he told mary neither do i condemn you
[Music]
go and sin no more because you took the
condemnation as you took our sins away
on the cross and paid the price
help us to know why you died and help us
lord to give up sin
because it hurts god the most
i pray that we all
would love
you now and forever
and do what you say because of love
thank you lord for saving my soul
thank you lord for making me whole
thank you for doing it for all of us
thank you thank you
thank you
in jesus name
amen
the sabbath we hope all of you were
blessed
by today's service
as mentioned in today's sermon
pastor mike reminds us that
the first trial of jesus was done by the
jews
the second trial was done by the romans
and the third trial
was a heavenly trial
[Music]
god had to forsake jesus on that cross
because god cannot be acquainted with
sin
[Music]
and jesus was bearing the sin of the
whole world
jesus died for fallen humanity
in isaiah we read that jesus had no
iniquity
yet we also read in isaiah 53 6 that the
lord laid all the iniquity of the world
unto jesus
jesus was crying on that cross
the angels were crying
and the father was crying
the lord cries for all of those who are
lost
those who have turned their back
on the lord
yes jesus died
but through his death we live
worthy
worthy is the lamb that was
slain because of the third trial of
jesus
we have hope
let us never forget the great sacrifice
of our lord and savior jesus christ
through him we have salvation
amen
thank you to all of those who have
decided to worship with us this sabbath
thank you for your continued prayers and
financial support to this media ministry
here at remnant is because because of
your prayers throughout the years that
we have been able to function
we have goals that we want to meet for
the media ministry
we're on a journey to discover new and
innovative ways
to make you part of this worship
experience but with that comes a
financial burden that we need to make in
order to make our goals a reality
if this ministry has been a blessing to
you we would like for you to continue
supporting us through your prayers and
through financial giving
the grace of god has been good to us
especially during this pandemic
so we can't be thankful enough for his
leading in this ministry
we would like to share this sentiment
with you by making you a part of this
media ministry here at remnant 7th day
adventist church
as we've said before we thank you for
supporting us in the past in the present
and we hope you still continue to
support us in the future
thank you
each and every single one of you for
supporting us and for growing with us
thank you for your love and support in
this ministry
please subscribe to our youtube channel
remnants sda church
don't forget that our praise and prayer
service is at 4pm so please join us as
we worship the lord together
with that being said we pray that the
following week is a excellent week
filled with blessings and praise
god bless you
thank you for joining us this sabbath
see you next week
you